ce soir notre performance va être
assurée par eric antoine
à propos de son spectacle réalité ou
illusion au palace alors le palace et
tous les lundis 2 décembre à 20 heures
est en ce moment en tournée dans toute
la france un eric antoine bonsoir
bonsoir
alors ce que vous voulez savoir ces 2
mai de 0,7 avant ou après érection
capillaire
c'est de mettre vingt sept après
puisqu'il ya sept centimètres des
réactions qui étaient là ce qui n'est
pas une très grande direction mais ce
n'est que du feu oui on peut pas là
alors on quand on est une mère
psychothérapeute et apple qui s'occupe
de dépression et qu'on lit dolto à 10
ans comment on fait pour s'en tirer
comme on fait disparaître ce genre de
phrase non mais c'est intéressant ça
donne un petit point de vue tu étais des
intuitions de l'autre dès le début des
attendre enfants sic
et quand ça commence le goût pour la
magie l'illusion quand est-ce qu'on
abandonne 2 le taux pour la baguette
magique et ben il ya quelque chose
d'affreux bien dans ce que mme une
affaire il ya
c'est un truc en fait je suis assez
grand et j'ai grandi très vite j'ai
grandi j'ai pris 30 cm un an et demi
j'étais bloqué au lit je pouvais plus
bouger
et comme je voulais plutôt je suis tombé
sur un bouquin magie et par hasard en
fait c'est des rencontres comme ça et
c'est ça qui m'a donné le goût à la
magie qui est je trouve être un havre
qui s'est ringardisé qui a mal vieilli
mais qui est hyper intéressant parce
qu'il parle si on peut l'utiliser pour
faire le faire délirer le faire parler
d'autre chose au travers la magie on
peut parler de la réalité dans laquelle
on vit qui parfois nous étouffe
mais qui peut être ailleurs à vous
parliez de la psychanalyse mais à un
moment il ya un gamin qui vient sur sur
scène et il ya un sac comme ça il va
mettre la main dans le sac
dix ans de psychanalyse quand même fait
remonter des enfants sur l'océan
elle est terrorisée comme ça oui autant
se battre avec des gens plus faible que
soi
oui non ça n'a pas d'intérêt si on prend
des plus fort que soi c'est dangereux
voilà donc autant traumatiser les
enfants rien de choses qui m'a étonné
dans votre spectacle une petite chose il
ya un moment vous danser ouais et vous
avez quand même une danse qui me semble
très orientale
alors oui c'était d'où vous vient ce
talent pour la danse orientale or c'est
le ba oui maman très bon temps mais il
ya plusieurs choses
calmez vous les mecs les filles vous
pouvez être à fond non mais en fait si
tu veux il ya quelque chose dans le
bassin comme ça mais moi ce que j'aime
surtout c'est la danse des fesses bien
c'est un truc comme ça et ça ça vient de
bâle où c'est le livre de la jungle j'ai
plusieurs ya quelques grands philosophes
dans le monde mais il ya balou et ya
homer simpson
bon alors j'ai entendu que vous aviez
essayé de braquer le public en demandant
à billets oui je vais faire je vais
faire une petite expérience sur l'argent
bah oui qui est quand même l'illusion
peut-être qu'il régit le monde ne l'a
plus autoritaire et puissante
donc on va essayer de faire délirer ça
un petit peu est ce que quelqu'un aurait
un billet de 5 10 20 ou 500 euros
quelque 1 500 euros tata 500 ha ben non
tu sors et la casse annoncée à combien
sur toi 20 euros c'est pas mal comment
vous appelez-vous typhaine
ça viendra la mode alors typhaine non
mais c'est pas mal était fait
est ce que vous savez comment on fait
pour vérifier si un billet vrai ou faux
non il ya plusieurs méthodes
donc en fait c'est pouvoir de magnétisme
c'est à dire si vous remarquez et
surtout les billes euros il ya une bande
magnétique est ici attention ambiances
magnétiques
[Musique]
c'est un vrai donc là on peut commencer
les expériences intéressantes sur
l'argent alors sur le sur le biais de
typhaine
alors tu prends vite ça fait flipper à
sétif m et l'actif m
quelle soirée de merde pour toi alors
vous en connaissez le matière par pliage
successives ou pliées en deux ou pliées
en quatre en huit comme ceci et puis
même en 16 es là il ya plus qu à déplier
et 20 euros deviennent 50 il y en a une
qui passe une bonne soirée taux normatif
et ne faut pas rêver on attend ce fait
500 je te rends tu plies rang 2 tu plie
en quatre suppléants luis tu pues ans et
là y'a plus qu'à déplier 500 un enfant
ça va mal ça monte
allez je te fais le 500 je veux tu te
calmes en huit ans c'est ça bon alors en
même temps cette période de crise vous
constaterez que l'argent n'est qu'une
illusion c'est pour ça je vous laisse
maintenant allez je vous montre plus
fort parce que voulait voir plus fort
oui jusqu'à l' mais vous d'accord vous
vous calmez maintenant parce qu'on peut
pas continuer l'émission nous avons dans
ce ton là alors c'est pas pousser les
gens sont dingues à temps oui voilà
tiphaine 1 entière m'a demandé à ce
jeune homme jeune homme commence
d'après-vous thomas thomas comme quoi tu
fais tes pas si pourri alors thomas tu
te suscinio billets afin de le rendre
unique au monde tu laisses le sud
marques distinctes ce que tu veux numéro
de carte bleue ça m'est égal ce que tu
veux ça juste que c'est strictement
interdit par la loi ce que tu es en
train de faire
ça s'appelle la détérioration du bien
public ou un briquet il est pas parfait
ah oui grâce à la signature tout à fait
inimitable de thomas le biais
maintenance unique au monde
voilà il ya un bon public alors petit
hommage culturel un chanteur français
disparu un dieu est un fumeur de havanes
tu vois et là tu roules le biais no
woman no koi no
là il faut bien faut bien rouler nos
âges et des petits soucis là à temps ou
et le briquet elle est là et la no money
no go même y en ait un qui comprennent
mais voilà qu'un autre biais
ou est-ce qu'il est passé le biais de
22,5 euros de thomas peut-être il est
dans le fruit défendu
est ce que tu veut fouiller tu fais le
fruit défendu
quand je parle du fruit défendu bien
entendu je parle de la pomme certifer ou
sinon peut-être le deuxième fruit
défendu
beaucoup moins connu là bas n'a
peut-être peut-être le troisième fruit
défendu encore moins connue le citron
mais ça c'est pour le zeste d'humour
fait pour it
tiphaine s'il vous plaît pour la
dernière fois vous êtes peut-être un peu
jeune tiphaine quel âge avez-vous 20 ans
dont c'est bon vous êtes majeur vous
avez des frères des soeurs en cas de
décès il ya du remplacement tout va bien
tu fais le jeu demandé de saisir avec la
main gauche un de ces trois fruits celui
que vous voulez d'accord avec notre main
vous saisissez un autre fruit essaye
encore rennais ne reste qu'un typhaine
le site ro si le billet signé de thomas
party fun et ce serait donne non vous
deviendriez une foule en tennis
je ne sais pas moi les plus grands vous
prendriez les plus petits frissons en
voyant l'est les femmes les fêtes dans
les maths
combien orléans est ce que tu veux
vérifier le couteau thomas vient
des fils coûte ou thomas vient vérifier
coup tout attention comme ça te paraît
normal oui très bien voulait vérifier le
citron thomas on m'a dit on n'a pas trop
le temps voilà vous pouvez un peu parlé
entre vous et dans le citron tu te
calmes pendant persie moi quelque chose
d'accord ce quelque chose qui me plaît
ma chaire tifa que vous leur thiriez
avec délicatesse du citron que vous
vérifiez qu'à la signature de ce matin
en regardant les mavs bien août face à
la caméra convoi qui est pas de
substitution possible la caméra là bas
allez-y tiphaine déplier le biais
vérifier s'il ya la signature de thomas
si tel est le cas je vais vous demander
de le montrer et de danser est ce qu'il
enseigne à 10
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup vous étiez comme sa
formidable série
[Musique]